un bonjour alors le bureau de vote où
vous vous trouvez est encore ouverte
pour l'art et oui tout à fait nada jeun
ce bureau de vote il est encore ouvert
ici à nanterre comme d'ailleurs à paris
ou dans le reste de l'agglomération
parisienne où les bureaux de forme des
voeux bureaux de vote ne ferme qu'à 20h
dans comme d'ailleurs dans d'autres
grandes villes et agglomérations en
france je pense à lyon à bordeaux à
nantes à lille à marseille ou encore à
nice alors dans sa ville les français
ont encore le temps de glisser dans
l'urne un bulletin en faveur d'une des
155 liste enregistré pour ces élections
régionales ce qui représente très
exactement nadège 19000 84 candidats au
total en revanche dans les communes de
taille plus modeste et bien les bureaux
de vote sont là fermé depuis 18 heures
alors qu vide au bio oblige à nadège et
bien ce scrutin a fait l'objet vous
l'imaginez d'un protocole sanitaire très
précis il a été demandé aux électeurs de
respecter une distance entre d'un mètre
cinquante minimum du le port du masque
était obligatoire du gel hydroalcoolique
a été mis à disposition des électeurs
les électeurs qui ont été d'ailleurs
incité à venir avec leur propre stylo
pour émarger et puis une limite de trois
votants maximum dans une même pièce a
été fixé six votants au maximum dans le
cas où les deux bureaux de vote se
trouvaient dans la même salle c'est à
dire les bureaux pour l'élection
régionale et pour l'élection
départementale car oui vous l'avez dit
nadège il s'agit aujourd'hui d'un double
scrutin
visiblement en tout cas pour l'heure
l'abstention atteint un taux record vous
savez vous de votre côté si les français
se sont déplacés pour ces élections
régionales et départementales en tout
cas du côté de l'inter
alors du côté de nanterre plus
spécifiquement on n'a pas encore les
chiffres en tout cas bien pas encore
bureau par bureau mais ça vous l'avez
vous l'avais déjà dit nadège visiblement
les français en tout cas ne se sont pas
déplacés il faut dire déjà qu'il ya eu
certains couacs l allumage de cette
journée d'élections régionales comme à
marseille par exemple certains électeurs
et bien ont trouvé portes closes en se
rendant à leur bureau de vote
la faute à un manque d'assesseurs si
l'on en croit la lfp alors à midi
le problème était résolu selon la mairie
phocéenne reste que le même phénomène a
été noté par exemple à saint-etienne
alors il convient de savoir si oui ou
non il s'agit il s'agit là d'un problème
plus global à une échelle bien plus
large qui aurait pu avoir une incidence
sur ce taux de participation car vous
l'avez dit nadal ce taux de
participation il est extrêmement faible
historiquement faibles puisque à 17
heures seuls 26 72 % des votants des 47
9 millions de personnes inscrites sur
les listes électorales avaient voté
c'est plus de 16 points de moins que
lors du premier tour des élections
régionales de 2015 ou la 43% des la
participation était de 43 % leur rendez
vous compte la neige cela signifie qu'à
17 heures plus de sept personnes sur dix
n'avaient pas fait le déplacement et
donc cela n'augure rien de bon pour le
taux de participation final on parle
d'une abstention record de plus de 65%
record car il veut
il apparaît bien que cette abstention
pour ces élections régionales pourrait
être la plus importante de toutes les
élections régionales de la cinquième
voire de toutes élections confondues de
la vème république
guillemin rezé en direct de nanterre
merci pour ces précisions on vous
retrouvera tout au long de cette soirée
pour faire le point sur sur ce scrutin
régional et départemental